what's going on reject nation Greg Alva
here John Humphrey over here we're gonna
check out from our friends over at art
spear entertainment to thor ragnarok
trailer smooth the toon sandwich series
man we've seen a whole bunch of ads for
this movie and boy oh boy does Thor look
unstoppable you know what else John
what's that Greg Alba I'm feeling
particularly unstoppable today thanks to
this snazzy new watch from Vince a big
thank you to those guys for sending over
these nifty timepieces to us if you guys
haven't heard of Inserra these guys are
makers are sharp luxury watches with a
distinct look and quality feel that's
really not gonna break the bank whether
you're heading out for a night on the
town are simply dressing to impress
Vince arrow actually III warden legit I
wore this watch to a wedding that went
to Colorado and it actually got a couple
compliments man I was the best-dressed
wedding see field report Vince arrows
goal is to make the modern gentlemen
feel and look unstoppable and as we've
all learned from countless films about
modern gentlemen a watch is a pretty
important accoutrement big words and you
will never be free from the cold and
indifferent passage of time these
watches are stainless steel and these
particular ones have marble in them and
all the watches come with scratch
resistant glass they're water-resistant
and they come with luminous hands so you
can keep track of the time even when the
Sun is gone whether you're in search of
that perfect gift for someone special or
you're just in the market for quality
watch it's not gonna cost you year's
allowance these are a great way to go if
you want one you could go to the link in
the description box below this video
enter our special code reel and get
yourself a nice little discount on a
brand new watch that I promise you
you're gonna love now let's check out
that Thor video let's do it no I'm just
gonna look at the top huh I love these
guys videos and they're cool guys unless
they a date you have given us permission
but now I know what you're thinking how
did this happen well it's a long story
this chain around myself and jumped in
this one's gonna have to take this from
if you're just gonna give it to me
Cheers Oh believe it me my father vision
now you is there anyone who isn't worthy
of this horrible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah we need to do something about those
doors I even agreed to cover his last
five ships for it with okra you missed
your last five shitty cover for me oh
hey when the business of hemorrhoid
prevention clinic ass got a son he ain't
got no chips
he asked yeah
goodbye doll then late-night stakeout to
run off later some ominous with the 20
you never appreciate how much mass
genocide truly means to you Angela's
been absent from your life
I got a haircut lost my Florentine locks
and you and I had a fight recently which
I won easily that doesn't sound right
that's true this is a flying saucers not
flying horses why come you chained up in
a bedroom because I've been a very
naughty boy haven't I Brucie I didn't do
this the hope must have done it
don't be coy big boy when you said you
were brings back friends you have a
dirty I like it I first want to say that
I'm flattered should always make sure
the gun works before announcing one's
presence
who needs space guns when you have small
knives and frankly I'm offended you
haven't heard of me
I'm a huge deal and if I didn't kill
everyone I meet a lot of folks we'll be
talking about me November when we
introduce ourselves
I'll speak first and say hello hello we
are and then I'll pause for a second so
we can all collectively say the as
guardians of the galaxy
ah
wash against my skin for each card
supports we're the same you and I just a
couple of one headed fools yes
Oh like raging volcano door like wisp of
steam from cup of chamomile tea it's
obvious you're just lashing out because
I'm worthy and you're not
we're League of heroes without seeking
justice with the Justice League
thora that name is being used by a
competing brand okay
we're a squad and this could almost be
considered a suicide suicide also - good
okay fine let's keep it simple
we're avenging Asgard we're the Avengers
not only is that an existing team you
yourself are an original member okay
let's work on the theme song I knew
something like and we're all pretty
fantastic Thor and the three unsupported
insensitive condescending killjoys Wow
do you that might have been one of their
best ones I've ever seen Mary Dewey yeah
that was hilarious
I like the pacing of it sometimes I feel
like especially with anything like this
type of animation or spoofing sometimes
the pacing can feel a little off to
Vassar chases time into many parts this
one the pace was just perfect throughout
yeah and they picked you know they
picked their scenes they made you know a
joke on the end of it moved on and yeah
I thought I mean this put a genuine
smile on my face especially like that
wrote Loki riff when they come in and
bedroom and stuff like that like I was
cracking me up that was like I bet Loki
would actually yeah thank you when I was
listening to a lot of their dialogue
action it was like a lot of this sounds
like stuff they would say like like it
all seems in context with the characters
as opposed to just breaking character to
make the joke yeah it's like if they
weren't concerned with the stakes this
is what they might talk about yeah yeah
yeah I really did appreciate that I love
like Nick Fury just making checks and
references the random flashback they
threw in NASCAR covering ships and all
that yeah yeah I thought this is clever
and very creative and yeah just like
life it didn't feel annoying and not
that they ever are I feel like any
channel like this spoofing is hard
spoofing a start because that's a
tendency to get annoying in certain bits
and I didn't find one bit of it to be
like eyes just too much or too little
this is perfect yes is there perfect one
yeah I thought they tailor it yeah
exactly
tailored all the jokes just the right
way and you know who pokes some loving
fun at Marvel yeah and an authority is
what I feel like that's part of what
makes a good spoof work is when you can
tell that there's love and understanding
underneath it while we're on ice and I
really got that from this art sphere
entertainment she's getting better
well done Tanner in bed remember
superhero Bowl I think does the first
one I ever saw from these guys the
fantastic job man arts your
entertainment subscriber these guys good
thanks for letting us react to your
videos I really do appreciate it
appreciate it actually sent these guys
an email okay well that's it for today
you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell he
is - on Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram you can check out
patreon.com/scishow to learn about
servants era collective man discount
code and they're real big thanks to them
again thanks again these are I think
mine's cooler than yours I think mine is
elegant and sophisticated and just
because I prefer the colors blue doesn't
mean I'm jealous I get one get the blue
or you could search the wide variety of
colors and styles available there are
different models
get the blue one and if you want to be
like cut the red wire